l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo
sotto al face quest
comunque siccome il primo tron face
questa aveva preso un casino siccome
aveva preso il casinò il primo non
vedevo l'ora di fare secondo perché vi
giuro giocare a sta roba mi mette molta
allegria non sapete quanto va bene sono
sono 20 i livelli di ok perfetto michael
prima dobbiamo dobbiamo riuscirci lo so
che sono impossibile a lei è un tipo
sexy lo faccia dire sembra un 3 face
attaccata dawn news selva non importa
comunque non faccio adesso che cazzo a
perfetto prendo questo grazie mille se
voleva me prima non è una cosa difficile
cos'è sta roba sono già tre vip
nightclub dobbiamo entrare
senta io sono fa vj non so se mi conosce
quindi far rientrare che si vive ti
piace giocare e sono angoli tipico due
cazzotti sulla faccia e allora non ero
pronto non ero pronto scusate mi devo
cliccare si cliccano le stelle si
cliccano che bello devo anno giorno
diventato uomo ragazzi non so perché
sono diventato obama ma adesso posso
entrare perché sono un gran filo ragazzi
non capisco neanche chi è sto tizio lo
farà una fototessera allora un bel
sorriso sono morto per una macchina
fotografica di solito le odio le foto
col the show ma questo cazzo mi sembra
esageratissimo devo prendere allora lei
che il dono tutti sto gioco abbiate un
porca [ __ ] non è che puoi chiudere gli
occhi nuova e rock non regga vi giuro mi
giurò che non lo so sono andato
completamente a caso vi giuro
poiché ho vinto ho vinto l'uccello di
prima se ragazzi ve lo devo dire un
astro uccello cazzo è un figo che non
avete da guardatevi come s'atteggia lo
chiamerò ugo a guardo guardando il
telescopio che cacciare di nuovo perché
ho perso
cioè io io guardo la luna che dorme ed e
perdo perché c'è una nuvola che è che fa
a devo spostare la nuvola come esposto
la numero c'è qualcosa da chi no no no
no ho sbagliato
sbagliato a cliccare ragazzi una
soluzione sarebbe gradita sveglia ci
sono negozio le ragazzo tirare la
testata mio dio
si si come cosa fatta
questo dopo un attimo non ho capito ho
cliccato ho cliccato sul giro c'è ma si
può essere più [ __ ] di così
mariah va beh io non ho capito che
questo è il momento sexy ragazzi
guardate come hanno censurato il
cervello del canarino e una cosa
incredibile ergo togliere la censura non
perfetto che devo aprire la doccia ok e
freddo allora con la casa o troppo
fredda troppo calda legge diteci
qualcosa gli angoli cos'è ma dov'è se vi
sembra giusto era la sua di doccia che
dovrà perfetto ma non ragazzi sta cosa
sa cosa inguardabile ma ok mi sa che o
sbaglio infatti è son due ragazze non ho
capito questa dovrei fare qui devo
smettere di bluff ma fermi un attimo
cesto tizio no no no no devo tentare di
non cadere nel momento in cui qui va
hugo film lo amo lo yo yo sposerò un
canarino stupido è il mio futuro questi
ragazzi velo preannuncio io te lo dico
sei un [ __ ] genio ugo sì esatto e la
cos'è madonna che sguardo che c'è questo
tizio devo passare in un metal detector
e mi sa che è effettivamente c'è il
motivo di suonare non ho capito perché
avevo che cosa fa cosa sta
riprogrammando il computer come farebbe
un vero professionista la cosa no no no
ho mai capito niente non devi suonare
l'ho rifatto riprogrammare apposta devo
e adesso adesso funziona
no non cos'è allora cosa serve anno il
suo sguardo spaventato ancor prima di
arrivarci al metal detector comunque non
ho capito no non funziona dall'abyan
capitola non sei tutto sottoposto di
scienza solo un cazzo di genio come
illudere la sicurezza internazionale
poi fa vigenti ragazzi sta cosa è ma
certo il genio il genio del noe non
condivido [ __ ] ragazzi è una donna
quanto incazzata la luna prima dormivo
adesso è incazzata devo pescare qualcosa
che forse qualcosa ha pescato me e la
cosa non è proprio uguale e che andavi
una mano ugo a parte urlare a cazzo
qualcosa la fai tutti che urlano
facciamo la zia orna anche tu urlo
anch'io
adesso forse si spaventa il mandante ho
vinto io chi cazzo è sto tizio ragazzi e
non importa ricordatevi soltanto quando
andate a pesca di urlare il più
possibile perché funziona sono sopra un
coso che non ho idea di come ci sia
arrivato qui sopra
marchon elicottero ok perfetto ovunque
salvo no come non detto e morto pazienza
povero devo devo buttarmi giù no magari
muoio anch'io se idee geniali non è che
me le mele studio mi vengono così a devo
allora l'elicottero certo diamo lo
facciamo qualcosa sono senso che li
ricotta lo abbiamo capito che non serve
a un cazzo magari mi tuffo mentre google
certo io
[Musica]
insieme perché io ti amo suu kyi ha
scherzato io devo dovuto farmi giù tutti
tuo figlio
[Musica]
stiamo livello siamo a metà occhielli
non ci crederete mai ma mi ricordo tutto
mi ricordo tutto quanto allora perfetto
questo questo qui olè no non era così
non era il primo c'è il primo c'è primo
centro c'è anche secondo mio dio che
potenza no no no mi piacerà l 83 su
questo non c'è cani non ce ne manca uno
cioè sono disfare come cazzo faccio re
start level devi toglierti non è
difficile ragazzi aiuto nichetti po
nascosti
[Musica]
abbiamo superato la metà lungo punto
dove cazzo eri prima che non c'è bisogno
di te stato sparato ugo in orbita non so
perché ma non importa come faccio a
raggiungere una caramella ragazzo
disperatamente bisogno di una rai che
sappia volare superman burgo dove siete
ragazzi ho bisogno di voi cosa che ho
fatto ho cliccato la cara mese scartata
da sola ho vinto non so come ok titta
tron l'unic tra brolo l'anica anzi
perfetto ed è affondata bene e vissero
tutti felici e fottutamente contenti
c'era una volta una bellissima nave che
incontrò un iceberg i due si
innamorarono vuoi la nave ci sbatte
contro e fondo fine questa regata ora in
poi la storia internazionale da
raccontare ai bambini prima di andare a
dormire
ok anche questa storia ha un lieto fine
ragazzi come sempre non è che poteva
finire così ciao bello squalo e senti
ugo mi dai una mano non perfetto tu
preferisci farsi il bagno senti bello
già che c'è un occhio bellissimo che mi
dai no perfetto mi ha mangiato pensavo
che fosse docile invece non si è
limitato a sbranarmi tranquillamente ugo
sei veramente d'aiuto
devo devo cosa devo fare qui no non è
che devo spaventarlo con hugo by hugo
boss salvami j l'occhio smercio cioè i
denti storti ci aiuta spero cosa diavolo
cliccato che non ho capito ho chiesto
tizio e poi mi manda ed è perfetto
e allora è utile c'è un tizio nella
bocca di di stop visto squalo usano fare
chi ce l'ha più grosso next level 11 0
57 vertici devo cercare l'oro
guardai natura ma non serve tua fa vj a
fatemi girarlo ora gira solo così abbia
questa cosa abbia
capito dove c'è il tizio che fa cucù che
non ho capito né chi cazzo è successo ok
ho vinto ho vinto e non so come ma va
bene così sinceramente sono più contento
devo cosa cosa fa se perché perché
incazzatevi andare al bagno deve fissare
amico mio ci sono meno 50 gradi e la
cosa e ho vinto
gn suo record per il livello fatto più
velocemente possibile
sì sì ho visto tutto vvt giuro che so
dove ci avrei scommesso in mezzo non è
in mezzo alla paglia minimo con la
sinistra non è che la sinistra non è con
la destra e quella in mezzo non è che i
ragazzi cè un culo che la metà bassa e
quella non è quella gesta porca [ __ ]
adesso andiamo avanti così tutta la
giornata
e questa non volevo cliccare la donna fu
ugo dammi la mano grazie ugo gradi
grazie non veramente grazie raggiungiamo
ad un accordo perché di sicuro c'è
qualcosa da cliccare che non vedo perchè
è una cosa che fa un pò schifo ma almeno
ho vinto sono veramente contento che ti
sia tolto qualcosa dal naso e non da
altre parks è sta roba per lungo ugo
salvalo tuo tavolo to grande uso
grandissimo finalmente ti rendi utile
stacchiamo la spina sono questo amore no
ancora e ancora allora fermi e non lo so
regalo la fatemi capire non
dovevo tenere premuto ok sono stato sono
stato un [ __ ] genio non chiedetemi
come ho fatto non lo so neanche io devo
cliccare ok burgo grande ho perso
infatti lui non vale una minchia ragazzi
non è no scherzavo dai che valeeva lì
tanto per me tu significhi tanto tra
l'altro che faccia contenta di giocare
sto tizio devo devo cosa devo fare
voglio provare a finirlo subito si mano
al grande lo sapevo lo sapevo ha [ __ ]
di brutto di brutto
credo che dobbiamo bere tra calici vuoti
fantastico no no sul co di uno che io ho
sempre pensato che hugo fosse letale ma
mai così siamo arrivati all'ultima dalla
capitano ed allora io so che jack
sparrow
non è un cazzo in confronto a te quindi
puoi darmi la chiave gentilmente perché
non sa anche che fu cota minavano tuo ok
se inciampato su una pistola la tua
utilità mi sorprende sempre devo dire
ritirare st bomba non perfetto neanche
quello io non ho il naso
ma che ca ma cos'è ma non ci voglio
credere io io non ho fottutamente parole
grazie ugo per avermi aiutato così tanto
sei stato veramente gentile sono sono
veramente onora cos'è a prestino ugo ci
sei tu in mezzo lo schema non avevo
dubbi
grandi ragazzi abbiamo scoperto che
abbiamo fatto tutto sto casino per poi
trovare ugo nello scrigno che è rimasto
sempre vicino a noi quindi potevamo
andarcene sin da subito va bè ragazzi
comunque dato che è di troll face quest
c'è anche il 3
voglio fare assolutamente anche quello
perché mi sembra veramente uno più
intelligente dell'altro ma dai ragazzi
comunque se vi do vi è piaciuto il corso
di dosso documento mi piace anche per
hugo è anche però anche a fagioli
facebook e come non i video trovate
nella descrizione senza rischi
iscrivetevi noi ci rimettiamo in un
prossimo vinto dai ragazzi
[Musica]